موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم افاد مراسل الجزيره
في السودان باندلاع معارك عنيفه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في مناطق عده
بمدن العاصمه الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري وام
درمان بعد انتهاء الهدنه العاشره واضاف
مراسلنا ان الطائرات الحربيه شاركت في هذه
الاشتباكات
وعربت الرياض واشنطن بصفتهما الميسره
لجهود وقف اطلاق النار بالسودان اعربت عن
اسافهم الشديد لعوده طرفي القتال في
السودان الى اعمال العنف فور انتهاء فتره
وقف اطلاق النار واكدت في بيان مشترك
ادانتهما بشده لتلك الاعمال ودعوتهما الى
وقفها فورا
تعقد منظمه ايجاد قمه اليوم في جيبوتي
تبحث قضايا افريقيه في مقدمتها الوضع في
السودان وقال الرئيس جيبوتي ان دول ايجاد
ستدرس سبل اقناع طرفي الازمه في السودان
باجراء حوار كفيل بيوقف اطلاق النار بشكل
فعلي من جهه ايداع الرئيس الكينيلا وضع حد
للحرب الدائره هناك
اعلنت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
استعاده الجيش الاوكراني السيطره على قريه
مكروفكا في منطقه ليرتفع عدد البلدات
المستعاده في تلك المنطقه امس الى الثلاث
وكانت القوات الاوكرانيه اعلنت استعاده
السيطره على بلدتي
وانسحاب القوات الروسيه منها
كما قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت
اربع طائرات روسيه مسيره خلال المعارك في
خرسون بينما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا بدات نقله وحدات من
النخبه من خرسون الى
المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
القوات الروسيه تصدت ثمانيه هجمات للجيش
الاوكراني على محور وثلاثه اخرى على محور
زبروجيا كما قالت الوزاره ان البحريه
الروسيه افشلت هجوما اوكرانيا بزوارق
مسيره على سفينه تابعه للاسطول الروسي في
البحر الاسود وان البحريه الروسيه دمرت
جميع الزوارق الاوكرانيه المهاجمه
قال المرشد الايراني علي خامنئيين بلاده
لا تعارض ابرام اتفاقيات بشان ملفها
النووي شريطه الحفاظ على البنيه التحتيه
لصناعه النوويه واضاف المرشد الايراني ان
من وصفهم بالاعداء يتخذون سلاح النوويه
ذريعه لمنع بلادهم من التقدم في المجالات
العلميه
وردا على تصريحات المرشد الايراني علي
خامن اقاله الخارجيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن
ملتزمه بعدم السماح ابدا لايران بامتلاك
سلاح نووي واضافت الخارجيه ان الدبلوماسيه
هي افضل سبيل لتحقيق هذا الهدف لكن الرئيس
بايدن كان واضحا ايضا بشان عدم استبعاد اي
خراء خيارات مطروحه على الطاوله
من جهته قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان
بلاده ستفعل كل ما يلزم لحمايه نفسها سواء
تم التوصل الى اتفاق مع ايران ام لا وان
اسرائيل لن تلتزم باي تسويه يتم التوصل
اليها مع ايران
ختام الموجز في امان الله